because this principle of interpretive
information plus other tools from
quantum information and fear of
entanglement is telling us that if we
successfully detect entanglement then
all theories that that claim that
gravity is classical are refuted it
doesn't say which quantum theory of
gravity we should pursue but at least it
tells us that this idea that gravity is
classical is definitely wrong and that's
quite beautiful and I think the good
news is that we're actually not that far
what do I mean by that well I try to
represent in this line a few nice masses
that the physicists that are working on
this bear in mind a lot so here on this
side before this pokéballs thing there
should be electrons and the neutrons and
things like that
bucky balls are 21 24 kilograms and
these objects can easily be put into
these special super positions by
experimentalist
then we have things like viruses and we
are actually almost there we you know we
can actually put a virus into a special
superposition almost I would say and
then there are objects like human cell
which are exactly the type of scale that
we need for this experiment so the
masses have to be quite heavy by the
standards of quantum theory but they are
not that bad and of course if you go
down this line at some point you hit
sometimes four kilograms which is which
is approximately the mass of
Schrodinger's cat which is what running
would have liked to see superpose and
and actually I would like also to see a
cat being superposed
but for that we have to wait likely for
the cat I would say and so this
same denotes exactly where we should be
in order for this experiment to be
realized and there is a race now because
this idea was proposed by a number of
people including me and other people
working in London and and then well
quantum gravity people's seem to have
been excited by this so their that they
are trying to think about it to improve
on the theoretical side and an
experimentalist what we have been
knocking at their doors trying to ask hi
can you superpose a human cell and they
say well not quite we can only superpose
buckyballs but we can try bit harder and
it depends on how much money we have and
so on
fortunately money comes always in it's
not very idealistic but that's that's
the way it is and that's what's
happening so people are trying to get
ready to do in this experiment and we're
very much hope in the despite of the
fact that this is very challenging just
because it's accessible in principle we
can realize it and this would be very
exciting because this would rule out all
of these theories that we've been
thinking about so far including
including strictly speaking also
classical theory of general relativity
this seems to be a good happy ending